[Musique]
bonsoir une crise peut en cacher une
autre et là c'est peut-être qui pourrait
durer plus longtemps derrière le coc
vida crise économique et ses
conséquences pour l'emploi les aides aux
entreprises permettent pour l'instant
d'amortir le choc de masquer la réalité
diraient certains
l'état s'apprête en tout cas à débloquer
des rallonges mais peut-être moins large
qu'au début la campagne de vaccination
qui ne fait que commencer
sera longue et n'empêchera peut-être pas
d'autres mesures plus strictes des
mesures sanitaires
la priorité en tout cas c'est d'éviter
un nouveau confinement le gouvernement
le dit et tout le monde l'espère pour
l'heure le coo vaut se généraliser à 18
heures entraîne déjà des complications
dans certaines entreprises voire dans
certains commerces
ce soir d'euros dition public le rendez
vous hebdomadaire lcp public sénat avec
le figaro je reçois elisabeth bornes
bonsoir poussins 10 de l'emploi du
travail et de l'insertion
merci d'être avec nous ce soir en plein
débat sur le vaccin
le groupe pharmaceutique sanofi français
annonce qu'il va supprimer 400 emplois
de chercheurs confirment parce que
c'était déjà un peu dans les tuyaux
c'est ressorti ce matin et le groupe le
confirme sanofi qu'il faut d'abord
trouver un vaccin d'ailleurs pourrait
produire pour l'américain pfizer ça
c'est une autre histoire mais annoncé
400 suppressions d'emplois de chercheurs
en pleine période mais pandémie est ce
que ça vous choque
écoutez moi toutes les annonces de
suppressions d'emplois dans la période
actuelle je trouve pas ça formidable je
pense qu'on est à un moment où la
situation est plus compliquée que
d'habitude sur le marché du travail et
donc c'est pas le moment d'envoyer des
salariés sur ce marché du travail mais
comme vous le dites c'est effectivement
la suite d' annonce qui avait été faite
en juin
évidemment gouvernement s'est assurée
que ça ne fragiliser pas sanofi par
rapport à cet objectif prioritaire dans
la course pour les vaccins moi
évidemment je vais me préoccuper que ça
se fasse sans licenciement sans départ
contraint et de façon générale on aura
l'occasion d'échanger avec sanofi pour
s'assurer qu'ils se saisissent bien de
tous les outils qui permettent de
protéger des emplois que ce soit
l'activité partielle où l'activité
partielle des emplois vous aimez
vous êtes mise de l'emploi plus
largement vous trouvez pas ça choquant
quand même que sanofi laboratoire
pharmaceutique disent là on cherche un
vaccin dans supprime 400 emplois de
chercheurs est ce que le gouvernement ne
va pas dire à un moment et qu'il faut
qu'ils renoncent le gouvernement va
s'assurer que sanofi tient les
engagements qui avaient été pris à
l'égard du président de la république au
mois de juin d'investir 600 millions
d'euros dans la recherche et
développement et de relocaliser en
france une usine de production de
vaccins donc on sera effectivement
vigilant à ce que ces engagements soient
bien respectées ça vous suffira comme
engagement vous la priorité c'est que
sanofi effectivement mettre le paquet en
terme de recherche et développement pour
développer un vaccin même avec des
charges de rang - moi je je je vous dis
ça ne ravit pas en effet que sanofi
annoncé la suppression alors on va
s'assurer que ça ne se fait pas avec des
départs contraints et que par ailleurs
sanofi met le paquet conformément à
l'engagement qui a été pris vis-à-vis du
président de la république pour
renforcer sa recherche développement
c'est pas les moyens légaux et les
moyens humains je veux dire c'est le
résultat on est attentif à la fois aux
moyens humains que sanofi s'empare de
tout l'est tous les dispositifs qui
permettent de protéger des emplois et
que sanofi
voilà répondre à notre ambition en
termes de recherche sur les vaccins et
de production en france de vaccins
quel que soit après ils gèrent leurs
effectifs et ça voulait dire au jeu
jeudi passant en tant que ministre du
travail je dis qu'en tant que ministre
du travail je me préoccupe par ailleurs
qu'on limite l'impact sur l'emploi est
qu on ne recourt pas à des départs
contraints voilà bien on va aller plus
loin maintenant avec mes deux concerts
des chaînes parlementaires brigitte
boucher bonsoir brigitte 2 traduit
bonsoir très tab
bon ça le sénat et c'est vous qui allez
poser la première question va continuer
à parler des entreprises parce que le
couvre-feu
évidemment des conséquences mais oui
aujourd'hui les entreprises les magasins
doivent fermer à 18h à cause du
couvre-feu
est-ce que vous inciter ses magasins
pour combler leurs manques à gagner à
étendre leurs horaires à ouvrir plus tôt
à ouvrir le dimanche
donc vous avez entendu le premier
ministre dans la conférence de presse de
jeudi dernier on a
effectivement incité les entreprises à
prendre des mesures pour étaler les flux
sur la journée sur la semaine sur la
journée ça veut dire être ferme être
pardon ouvert à l'heure du déjeuner donc
ça suppose d'adapter les horaires entre
midi et dialogues avoir plutôt si pour
certains qu'ils devraient plutôt être
ouvert à l'heure du déjeuner et puis on
a invité les commerçants à s'emparer des
dérogations qui ont été prises par les
préfets sur l'ouverture du dimanche
savez qu'il ya près des trois-quarts des
départements dans lequel les
concertations qui ont été menées comme
je l'avais demandé je l'avais demandé
début décembre que de se préparer à des
ouvertures du dimanche en janvier et
dans des trois-quarts des départements
des dérogations existent donc on invite
les commerçants à se saisir mais aussi
en février en février également
notamment pour les deux dimanche de
soldes qui va y avoir pour les deux
premiers dimanches de février alors sur
les dimanches de soldes il ya déjà des
dérogations qui ont été accordés dans
beaucoup de cas et moi j'ai demandé au
préfet de reprendre les concertations
pour si on devait prolonger ce
couvre-feu à glace vient d'heure au delà
de 15 jours être prêt à voir mener les
concertations permettant le cas échéant
de prévoir aussi des ouvertures
dominicales et l'adorent février en
février vous voyez c'est pas facile pour
les salariés évidemment de s'adapter à
ces nouveaux horaires à ces ouvertures
le dimanche
est ce que vous ne craignez pas que ce
soit aussi source de litiges et de
possibles licenciements
enfin je pense que je ne vois vraiment
pas pourquoi ça pourrait déboucher sur
des licenciements 1 ce qui est très
clair par exemple s'agissant du travail
du dimanche
françafrique ça ne peut se faire ça ne
peut se faire que sur la base du
volontariat le code du travail est
parfaitement limpide sur le sujet et ça
doit s'accompagner de compensation à la
fois en termes de rémunération et de
reposer pour le savoir mais imaginez
quelqu'un qui dise moi je peux pas venir
travailler à 7 heures du matin parce que
je travaillais à 9 heures j'ai des
enfants etc
ça peut créer des tensions dans les
entreprises ça peut même aboutir à des
litiges
écoutez je pense que tout le monde est
conscient qu'on vit une période
absolument atypique extraordinaire que
on a besoin de pouvoir s'adapter pour
répondre
quand on est dans un commerce aux
besoins des français donc moi je fais
confiance au dialogue dans les
entreprises qui ont démontré tous ces
derniers mois que le dialogue social
ça fonctionne ça permet ça a permis par
exemple de rouvrir après le confinement
avec des mesures sanitaires qui ont
assuré aux salariés qu'ils pouvaient
venir et travailler en sécurité
donc je pense qu'il faut aussi faire
confiance au dialogue social alors alors
que le couvre feu est en est en vigueur
à 18h depuis samedi est ce que vous vous
demandez aux entreprises de privilégier
au maximum le télétravail afin qu'un
maximum de personnes soit chez elle à
partir de 18 heures alors on préconise
en effet de recourir au maximum au
télétravail vous savez que au moment au
début du 2ème confinement on avait
demandé que toutes les tâches qui
peuvent être faites à distance soit fait
en télétravail est donc que si un
salarié avait toutes ces tâches dans
cette situation il soit en télétravail
cinq jours sur cinq
cette règle on l'a un peu assouplie
depuis le 7 janvier
parce qu on a aussi entendu que des
salariés qui sont depuis deux mois en
télétravail cinq jours sur 5 souffrent
d'isolement et donc on a demandé aux
entreprises de permettre pour les
salariés qui en expriment le besoin de
revenir justement est ce que vous
pourriez revenir sur cette journée
accordé si toutefois l'épidémie continue
alors non je pense qu'on a des enjeux de
santé publique qui doivent être pris en
compte dans les deux cas évidemment on à
cette épidémie de covin 19 et on a aussi
des problèmes psychologiques des
problèmes de souffrance qui sont
exprimées par les salariés donc ça veut
dire aussi avec ses le télétravail sauf
une journée par semaine c'est la norme
la règle c'est effectivement le
télétravail cinq jours sur cinq pour les
postes qui le permettent
par contre quand un salarié en expriment
le besoin il peut revenir au maximum une
journée dans les ca vous ne reviendrai
pas là dessus et nous n'avons pas prévu
de changer cette règle sur les vaccins
d'entreprises parce que ça aussi les
vaccins on en parle beaucoup au gîte
oui vous avez vous entrepris d'ailleurs
favorable à la vaccination en entreprise
est ce qu'il ya des discussions qui sont
menées actuellement et sur quoi
précisément
alors c'est un peu prématuré puisque
vous avez vu que dans notre stratégie
vaccinale
on privilégie pour l'instant vaccins des
personnes âgées des personnes
vulnérables
mais quand on passera à une vague de
vaccination plus large
je pense que les entreprises démontrent
tous les ans notamment au moment de la
vaccination contre la grippe qu'elles
savent aussi participé à ces stratégies
vaccinales et donc je pense que le
moment venu elles pourront aussi être
acteur et quand vous l'espérez on a
d'abord à vacciner les 15 millions de
personnes vulnérables
donc c'est vraiment la priorité parce
que c'est ce qui nous permettra de ne
plus avoir un risque pour ces personnes
qui peuvent développer des formes graves
et de plus avoir ce risque non plus
d'avoir une saturation de nous personne
l'ordination vénérable pas forcément les
personnes âgées
il peut y avoir des personnes
prioritaires aussi dans les entreprises
est ce que ça vous l'avais envisagé est
ce qu'elles devraient être prioritaires
justement et des secteurs clés secteur
wii qui serait à ce star iv sur la
stratégie qui a été présenté des
personnes âgées en priorité dans les
ehpad depuis aujourd'hui les personnes
de plus de 75 ans et puis donc les
soignants de plus de 50 ans et les
personnes vulnérables qui ont des
pathologies particulières vous avez pas
anticipé pour les entreprises justement
je n'ai pas des secteurs très touchés on
l'a vu dans les abattoirs par exemple
dans la distribution parce que c'est un
secteur qui doit tourner absolument
pendant là ce sont des discussions qu'on
aura le moment venu quand on aura assuré
la vaccination de ce ces personnes
prioritaires de ses 15 millions de
personnes sans savait pas ce n'est pas
fair n'est pas encore à l'ordre du jour
on prendra le moment venu des
discussions sur ces sujets est ce que
vous diriez y la bête bande que la
reprise de l'économie dépend aussi du
vaccin
une semaine de retard de vaccin coûte 2
milliards à l'économie a estimé
l'économiste philippe martin oui je
pense que vous savez c'est un petit peu
vision enfin je vois bien que c'est fait
avec le ratio de ce qu'on peut avoir
quand on est amené à faire un
confinement tous les pays en europe ont
eu des doses de vaccins de façon
équitable au prorata de leur population
on a vu que certains pays ont démarré
plus vite et peuvent du coup se
retrouver en attente de nouvelles
livraisons de vaccins nous on a un
objectif qui est simple c'est tenir
l'objectif d'un million de personnes
vaccinées en janvier 20 janvier et
vacciner le plus vite possible et 15
millions pour vous reposer la question
de table est ce que vous diriez que la
reprise de l'économie dépend du vaccin
pas ce qui est très clair c'est à la
fois qu'on a toute une partie de notre
économie qui continue à tourner on l'a
vu en novembre lors du deuxième
confinement et toute une partie de
l'économie l'industrie le btp qui ont
continué à tourner il ya une partie de
notre économie qui représente 10 à 15%
de l'activité économique qui est
fortement pénalisée par les mesures
sanitaires qu'on est amené à prendre
pour faire face à ces évolutions de
l'épidémie donc évidemment c'est très
important pour qu'on retourne tout le
monde ne sera pas vaccinés on ne pourra
pas avoir l'ensemble de l'économie qui
pourra repartir
alors moi je ne suis pas épidémiologue
on peut penser que quand on aura quinze
millions de personnes vulnérables
vacciner l'épidémie n'aura plus les
mêmes conséquences on n'aura plus la
crainte pour la vie de ces personnes et
on n'aura plus la crainte d'une
saturation dernière question sur le
rapide pour l'instant le gouvernement
dit un non au passeport vaccinale tout
le monde toute façon on ne peut pas être
vaccinés pour l'instant mais ce que mme
au moment où tout le monde pourra l'être
il y aura suffisamment de vaccins pour
tout le monde un passe temps national
pourra pour vous s'appliquer s'appliquer
notamment au monde de l'entreprise
il faudra être obligatoirement vacciner
pour aller travailler
enfin c'est pas du tout envisagé
aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit ça n'est pas
un vaccin obligatoire et donc ça n'est
pas l'employeur qui va pouvoir décider
de demander un certificat de vaccination
à ses salariés ça ce n'est pas possible
alors on va parler maintenant avec vos
brigitte puisque dans la foulée de ce
que vous venez de dire du chômage
partiel parce que le chômage partiel a
été débloquée en france est une question
qui se pose logique parce que la france
est le pays européen qui
il ya le plus recours combien ça a coûté
à l'état et l'unedic alors ça a coûté à
peu près 30 milliards à ce jour sur
l'année 2020 à d'accord et on a prévu
plus de 10 milliards sur l'année
2021 parce que je pense que c'est très
important on l'a dit il ya des secteurs
qui sont encore pénalisés il faut
continuer à les accompagner aussi
longtemps que nécessaire et il ya eu des
abus à hauteur de combien il ya eu
énormément de contrôle on est à je crois
550000 contrôle on a finalement très peu
de fraudes d'escroquerie d'abus tu sais
quoi en terme de pourcentage à
représente je vous ai dit le chiffre de
dépenses en 2020 donc 30 milliards on à
180 millions d'euros sur lesquels on a
eu des suspicions de fraudes ou des
fraudes
et sur ce montant là on a pu en bloquer
on va dire en bloquer ou récupérer 160
millions il ya vingt millions qu'on est
encore peu finalement
je pense que ça montre que très
largement ça a été utilisé à bon escient
et en tout cas les services du ministère
du travail sont très vigilants et les
contrôles continus et les contrôles
continus a priori c'est à dire avant de
payer et a posteriori pour aller
vérifier que l'argent est bien une femme
toujours sur le chômage partiel oui vous
allez durcir dans les conditions du
chômage partiel en février
non on a annoncé qu'on prolonge et les
conditions identiques
enfin au maintien jusqu'à fin février
les règles qui s'appliquent
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'il ya deux
catégories les secteurs fermés les
secteurs prioritaires ça on a vu que ce
soit la priorité en restauration
donc ces secteurs-là jusqu'à fin février
ils sont pris en charge à 100 % et les
autres recrues qui ont aujourd'hui un
reste à charge de 15% le garderont
jusqu'à fin février et ensuite ça
passera ça doit passer à 40%
mais les entreprises est-ce que se
saisir de l'activité partielle de longue
durée c'est-à-dire conclure un accord
au sein de l'entreprise ou en s'appuyant
sur un accord de branche on a trente
huit branches professionnelles qui ont
négocié un accord de branche donc ça
permet aux entreprises de se saisir
facilement du dispositif d'activité
partielle de longue durée
et quand on a un accord d'activité
alors on peut cependant être accompagnée
avec ce reste à charge de 15%
pendant deux ans il faut que ce soit -
l'état quand même qu'ils financent ceux
y songe que l'état finance mois l'état
financement qui soit deux seulement
présent pour les secteurs prioritaires
et que pour l'idée asseoir l'idée c'est
de dire que l'état doit accompagner
aussi longtemps que nécessaire
les secteurs qui ont en encore
aujourd'hui des contraintes du fait de
la situation sanitaire que les autres
secteurs on les invite à recourir à
l'activité partielle de longue durée
parce que c'est important quand on pense
qu'on a une activité qui va être
durablement en dessous de ce qu'elle
était avant la crise qu'on partage cette
vision avec les salariés qu'on puisse
aussi et je pense que c'est très
important parce que vraiment l'activité
partielle de longue durée c'est un outil
deux en un ça permet à la fois de
protéger des emplois et ça permet
d'utiliser les périodes où les salariés
ne travaillent pas pour se former et je
crois que c'est vraiment important que
on se dise que les salariés vont pouvoir
avoir des formations par exemple sur la
transition digital ou pour adapter les
compétences en tenant compte de la
transition écologique et que nos
entreprises soient plus fortes en sortie
de crise parce que les salariés ont pu
être formé alors ça c'est pour le
chômage partiel liée au corona virus
mais il ya le chômage dans sa globalité
qui risque d'exploser évidemment
brigitte et la question se pose sur la
surenchère sur l'assurance chômage parce
que la réforme a été reportée plusieurs
fois elle ne doit entrer en vigueur
maintenant c'est prévu le 1er avril et
les syndicats eux demandent toujours
leur abandon vous allez reprendre les
discussions à partir du 25 janvier il me
semble est-ce que vous pensez que cette
réforme a un avenir
d'abord vous dire que évidemment
l'objectif c'est que on qu'on tienne au
maximum l'augmentation du chômage et on
a pu voir que jusqu'à présent l'impact
de la crise
sur l'emploi a pu être relativement
contenu justement grâce aux mesures
d'urgence on a parlé de l'activité
partielle on peut aussi parler du plan
un jeune une solution pour permettre aux
jeunes d'être le moins pénalisés
possible dans la situation que l'on
connaît les deux fuyards étaient en
contexte on peut la faire cette réforme
quand même ça veut dire que bien
évidemment il s'agit pas de mettre en
oeuvre la réforme qui avait été imaginé
en 2019 et c'est bien pour ça que nous
avons eu des discussions avec les
organisations syndicales et patronales
on les a eus notamment en cette fin
d'année fin de l'année dernière et moi
je souhaite reprendre les concertations
pour trouver voilà la bonne réforme à
mettre en oeuvre dans ce contexte je
pense que l'idée de dire qu'on veut
dissuader le recours excessif aux
contrats courts avec notamment le
système de bonus malus je crois que la
crise nous a montré à quel point les
salariés qui enchaîne des contrats
courts sont fragilisés quand on traverse
ça veut dire jacques dion pendant ce
quinquennat il y aura bien une réforme
de l'assurance chômage
à l'issue de ce quinquennat je vous
confirme que l'objectif c'est bien
d'aboutir sur cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage avec notamment un
enjeu pendant ce quinquennat
absolument mais je vous posais
quinquennat ce quinquennat si donc
d'aboutir sur cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage / à la fois la lutte
contre la précarité liée au recours
excessif aux contrats courts et puis
également d'avoir plus d'équité dans le
calcul de l'allocation chômage parce que
le système actuel il est loin d'être
parfait vous voyez quand vous travaillez
par exemple tous les jours à mi temps
vous avez une allocation qui à peu près
la moitié de ce que vous avez quand vous
travaillez à temps plein un jour sur
deux donc je pense qu'on peut aussi
travailler sur quelque chose de plus
juste on va terminer sur les jeunes de
questions
taris alors un million et demi de jeunes
sont aujourd'hui en situation de
pauvreté vous dit toujours non au rsa
jeune elizabeth bornes on apporte une
réponse assez jeune on apporte une
réponse qui passe par un accompagnement
pour que les jeunes pour que tous les
jeunes puissent bâtir un projet
professionnel et qu'on les accompagne
pour le réaliser vous dites nous alors
le rsa jeunes au sens une allocation
sans accompagnement comme le rsa est
devenu ça je vous dis franchement ça
n'est pas notre projet pour la jeunesse
même autrement l'algérie circonscrire la
crise mais situations d'urgence comme le
demande et nous sommes ni vielles force
que ce que nous faisons c'est mieux nous
donnons la possibilité
l'objectif c'est vraiment que chaque
jeune puisse bénéficier d'un
accompagnement par une mission locale
par pôle emploi par l'apec pour les
jeunes diplômés
quand il rentre dans un accompagnement
nous avons doublé le nombre de places
offertes en garantie jeunes on en aura
200 milles cette année et au total on a
près d'un million de dispositifs de
solutions pour les jeunes dans lesquels
on leur propose à la fois un
accompagnement et une rémunération
jusqu'à 500 euros par mois pour ceux qui
en ont besoin il peut passer aussi par
l'apprentissage
régis oui alors l'apprentissage est bien
cent cinquante mille jeunes g450 sont
tournés vers l'apprentissage
il trouve pas toujours d'entreprise pour
les accueillir ensuite est-ce que ses
responsables à l'état de la part de
l'état de les encourager à aller dans
ces filières là alors que derrière il
n'y a pas d'entreprise
non je pense qu'on ne peut pas dire ça
comme vous l'avait dit il ya 450 plus de
450 mille jeunes qui ont signé un
contrat d'apprentissage ça veut dire
qu'ils ont une entreprise qu'ils ont pu
trouver une entreprise où ils peuvent se
former effectivement pendant les rares
amis il ya de l'ordre de 38 mille jeunes
sans contrat on est en train de regarder
ces situations je pense qu'il ya des
organismes de formation qui n'ont pas
totalement joué le jeu se sont
engouffrés dans la brèche et qui font
payer des frais de scolarité alors que
derrière il n'y a pas d'entreprise pour
accueillir les jeunes
il ya une forme d' arnaque l'ain alors
moi je ne vais pas me prononcer avant
qu'on est chez les contrôles mais je
peux vous dire que les contrôles sont en
cours
ça n'est pas ça l'esprit de
l'apprentissage l'apprentissage d'abord
ce doit être gratuit y a pas de frais
d'inscription et il appartient au centre
de formation de d'accompagner le jeune
pour qu'ils trouvent une autre quand
vous dites que les contrôles sont en
course avis qui quoi qu'on bien où on a
un certain nombre de centres de
formation fin de d'organismes de
formation qui se sont déclarés centre de
formation pour les apprentis pendant la
crise en particulier de l'effet
d'aubaine près depuis la rentrée et qui
a ont un nombre conséquent de jeunes
supposés être en apprentissage dont un
pourcentage très élevé n'a pas
d'entreprise voilà donc on va faire des
vous avez pas combien de jeunes encore à
peu près sur le tissu moi je peux vous
dire qu on a onze mille jeunes qui sont
dans cette situation là et donc on va
faire les contrôles sur les quelques
organismes de formations qui comptent
sur les doigts d'une main les oripeaux
de formation peu plus de tête les deux
mains les deux mains en d'accord plutôt
une dizaine voile rideau qui aura des
sanctions
évidemment si c'est une fraude il y aura
des sanctions le saura bientôt sam et
donc du coup on va faire ces contrôles
et puis par ailleurs il ya des jeunes
qui sont réellement dans un centre de
formation d'apprentis qui les préparent
par exemple aux métiers du bâtiment par
exemple
un métier artisanal et qui n'ont pas
encore trouvé une entreprise je peux
vous dire qu'on va retrousser les
manches avec les chambres de commerce
avec les années les élections et on va
les aider pour trouver évidemment une
entreprise merci brigitte etam est
évidemment l'un des prochains jours ni
sur vous philippe martinez sur france
info ce matin lui il a peut être une
piste pour essayer de limiter les dégâts
en terme de chômage
vous allez entendre le numéro un de la
cgt qui propose une réduction du temps
de travail
vous savez peut-être nous avons proposé
au gouvernement de baisser le temps de
travail justement pour s'adapter à ces
nouvelles contraintes liées au couvre le
fossé terrier qu'on passe à combien bref
ça dépend des entreprises mais on
pourrait repartir une heure plus tôt
tous les jours par exemple ou libérer
une après midi pour faire des tâches
quotidiennes qu'on peut plus faire parce
qu'il ya le couvre-feu d'abord qu'il ya
une certaine constance dans ses
propositions je pense que ça fait
longtemps effectivement qui peut porter
ce genre de sujet je crois qu'il faut
pas confondre deux choses la nécessité
dans les entreprises de tenir compte du
contexte créé par le couvre-feu est donc
de donner de la souplesse aux salariés
pour qu'ils puissent le cas échéant
aller faire leurs courses et la question
générale de la réduction du temps de
travail dont je pense que c'est pas le
débat du moment elle n'est pas sur la
table cette question là je vous confirme
que de ma part elle n'est pas sur la
table et j'entends que monsieur martinez
voudrait y caser chienlit mètres mais en
tout cas je crois que c'est pas le sujet
du moment
par contre on ne peut qu'inviter les
entreprises à donner de la souplesse aux
salariés pour qu'ils puissent
s'organiser avec le couvre-feu à 18 yves
thréard du figaro yves thuriès et
directeur adjoint du journal est avec
nous comme tous les lundis soir bonsoir
yves bonsoir francis assister un peu
d'eux-mêmes ils emploient proprement dit
pour parler de sujets qui font quand
même des bons moments la laïcité par
exemple oui alors il ya comme vous le
savez madame la ministre un projet de
loi qui est arrivé aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs en commission à l'assemblée
nationale sur pour renforcer je dirais
des valeurs les principes républicains
évidemment ça couvre l'ensemble de la
société mais vous êtes ministre du
travail
est-ce que des dispositions vont être
prises
justement pour lutter contre l'islamisme
comme l'appelle gilles kepel l'islamisme
d'atmosphère dans les entreprises
alors je pense qu'il faut sérier les
sujets dans le cadre de ce projet de loi
vous avez vu qu'on va inscrire dans la
loi le fait que un principe de
neutralité s'appliquent aux agents du
service public oui mais aussi aux
entreprises privées qui ont des missions
de service public donc ça c'est le
principe de neutralité de l'état est
neutre et donc toutes les missions de
service public doivent respecter le
principe de neutralité
alors madame genevard qui est députée
d'iberville audriaz pardon je situe
110,4 les républicains qui dit il
faudrait aussi que les usagers des
services publics se soumettent à ce
régime
alors là je pense que c'est autre chose
c'est changer la loi de 1905 un cause un
principe de liberté
donc on est dans un pays qui depuis
maintenant plus d'un siècle a posé un
principe de liberté de culte de libertés
dans l'espace public avec par contre
l'état qui est neutre et donc les agents
du service public sont neutres alors on
peut revenir sur les principes de la loi
de 1905 mais je pense pas que ce soit
l'objectif du moment vous d'accord alors
il ya une députée de la majorité cette
fois mais rejeté présidentielle d'amour
aux bergers qui s'est vue retoqué un
amendement disant qu' il aurait fallu
selon elle que les fillettes ça soit
interdit aux filles est d'être voilées
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de ça je
pense là aussi vous savez je les dis
qu'il ya des sujets enfin sur le la
tenue dans l'espace public
il ya un principe qui prévaut en france
qu'il n'y a pas de contraintes sur les
tenues emporte dans l'espace public donc
ça veut dire pour le voile intégral sauf
qu'on le voile intégral quand on passe
que son visage dans ce cas là c'est
interdit mais pour le reste vous pouvez
déplacer avec une soutane pouvons avoir
une kippa vous pouvez avoir un voile
c'est le principe de liberté
d'abord de culte en france et de liberté
dans l'espace puisque la soutane c'est
pour je dirais des jazz air sain
magistère alors que le voile par
définition ça peut être des citoyens et
la kippa et des signes voilà donc je
pense que c'est important de rester sur
les principes fondateurs de la loi de
1905 sur la liberté de culte et sur la
liberté dans l'espace public sur ce
sujet vous avez dirigé la ratp
est ce que c'est un vrai sujet qui
aujourd'hui préoccupe les entreprises
notamment les entreprises publiques que
celui justement de la montée de
l'islamisme quand on manque des heures
de prière quand on demande quand on veut
pas travailler dans la mixité quand est
ce que c'est quelque chose à laquelle
vous vous avez été confronté alors c'est
effectivement un sujet qui est important
en entreprise qu'il n'y ait pas des
demandes de salariés qui viennent à la
fois entre venir à ses principes de
neutralité quand on est dans une
entreprise qui a une mission de service
public
et puis par ailleurs qu'ils peuvent
dégrader les relations entre les
salariés
moi en tant que pdg de la ratp je peux
vous assurer que je ne tolérerai pas
qu'un salarié accepte de serrer la main
des messieurs c'était une époque où on
se serrait les mains donc aujourd'hui un
certain bagage ans pose plus ce sujet se
pose plus mais en tout cas voyez moi je
ne te laisserai pas qu'un salarié serre
la main de ses collègues hommes et
refuse de serrer la main de ses
collègues femmes parce que c'est un
principe de non discrimination
donc moi je n'ai jamais accepté ça je
pense que c'est important que les
entreprises soient vigilantes sur le
fait qu'il n'ya pas justement des
discriminations hommes femmes en
entreprise
bono le maire qui vient d'écrire un
livre
langer la bête pour reprendre une
formule pascalienne dit que la sortie de
crise va être très très très très
difficile et se profile évidemment
l'élection présidentielle d'ici à 14
mois d'après vous quel va être le sujet
central est ce que ça va être cette
crise sanitaire
nous vient on sait de chine mais qui
nous est tombé sur la tête sur la tête
ou est ce que vont se greffer là-dessus
des problèmes d'ordre sécuritaire
l'attentât et des problèmes d'ordre
économique comme le dit bruno le maire
avec la menace d'un chômage de masse
avec la menace de faillite en pagaille
savez je pense que tous ceux qui sont
essayés à prévoir sur quoi ce jour est
une élection générale
voilà ont été démenties par les faits ce
qui est très clair c'est qu'on vit une
période dans laquelle on a des crises
multiples on avait une crise écologique
kipré préexisté à la crise sanitaire on
a maintenant cette crise sanitaire fait
tout pour la surmonter
évidemment il ya la crise économique
pour lequel là aussi on mobilise tous
nos moyens pour en réduire l'impact
et puis on a en effet aussi des enjeux
de sécurité
donc je peux vous assurer que le
gouvernement est mobilisé et enfin moi
je suis pas en train de me demander sur
quoi se jouera l'élection de 2022 je
suis dans mon champ en train d'agir du
matin au soir chaque jour de la semaine
pour protéger au maximum les emplois
pour permettre aux entreprises de
conserver leurs compétences pour
permettre aux jeunes d'être le moins
pénalisés possible dans la crise et tout
le plan condé loi pour permettre aux
jeunes d'accéder à une formation vers un
métier qui recrute et à un emploi de
petite dernière question vous parler
d'élection il ya des élections
régionales qui dorment allemand devrait
avoir lieu au mois de juin
vous serez candidate en normandie alors
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire que j'étais
intéressé par un mandat local que compte
tenu de mes responsabilités au
gouvernement je ne pourrais pas être
tête de liste est ce que voit l'amour ma
mission n'est pas compatible avec une
position de tête de liste mais je vais
regarder comment je peux être impliqué
dans lundi dallas donc candidate
et si ces élections ne peuvent pas avoir
lieu au printemps enfin mois de juin il
faut les repousser après l'élection
présidentielle
je pense qu'ensuite enfin le débat il
aura lieu un nez sur une science de juin
le débat a lieu demain au sénat on va
pas
en train de se demander ce qui va se
passer si jamais ça n'est pas possible
ensuite c'est vrai qu'on va pas non plus
faire des élections régionales à la
veille des élections présidentielles
françaises dépassées merci merci francis
séparent lille bruno le maire tout à
l'heure ils vont voir parler de bruno le
maire -ministre de l'économie qui devant
la délégation des droits des femmes de
l'assemblée nationale cet après-midi
s'est dit favorable à des quotas
je le fais pour résumer pour favoriser
l'emploi des femmes et l'égalité dans
les entreprises et d'égalité avec les
hommes
il estime même qu'il faut une loi
premier point sur lequel je veux
insister c'est que je suis favorable à
une approche volontariste beaucoup plus
qu'une approche progressive
je suis favorable à des quotas et je
suis favorable à des délais rapides il
est évident que ce sera plus difficile
de parvenir à la parité dans les comics
dans le secteur de l'industrie
métallurgique plutôt que dans les
services services à la personne par
exemple où on a déjà quasiment la parité
alors ils avaient deux bornes est ce
qu'il faut des quotas dans les
entreprises pour favoriser l'égalité
hommes femmes au travail
vous savez depuis l'année 2019 je crois
on a déjà un index égalité homme femme
qui pointe un certain nombre de sujets
et je crois que cet exercice il a eu
vraiment le mérite de mettre de la
transparence sur les sujets du négoce
ville d'aix pour l'année qui vient pour
l'année qui vient de passer alors cet
index
il a montré que la transparence oblige
les entreprises à progresser on l'a vu
tout les notes des entreprises ont pu
progresser celle qui était en dessous
des 75 points sur 100 se sont saisis je
pense qu'il ya un enjeu de réputation
est donc ce type d'index a un effet
vraiment très clair sur le comportement
des entreprises mais on en parle souvent
avec bruno le maire on partage le fait
que aujourd'hui encore près de 40 % des
entreprises ont moins de deux femmes
parmi les dix plus autres et ça sert à
ça et ça ça n'a pas bougé
ça n'était pas non plus dans à leur ex
jusqu'à présent moi je pense qu'il faut
absolument aller vers des objectifs
d'équilibré femmes
oui mais alors est-ce que ça passe par
une loi imposant des quotas
ça passe par une loi demandant aux
entreprises d'abord d'être transparents
sur la part des femmes parmi les cadres
dirigeants on a engagé des concertations
avec les organisations patronales et
syndicales certains nous disent faut pas
parler de quatre dirigeants vous parlez
des 10% de postes à plus forte
responsabilité cdd bacon bio unique il
faudra passer par la loi pour yariv ben
je pense qu'en tout cas de dire que
enfin la loi oblige à présenter la part
des femmes parmi les cadres dirigeants
ou en tout cas les postes à plus fortes
responsabilités avec des objectifs de
tendre vers une parité au sein de ses
cadres dirigeants je pense que c'est
indispensable idée de quotas je sais pas
ce qu'on appelle quotas ce que je
relevais lady d'écouteurs ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que je pense que de la
même façon que la loi copé zimmermann
dont on fêtera prochainement les 10 ans
a permis de renouveler les conseils
d'administration de s'assurer qu'on a au
moins 40% de femmes dans les conseils
d'administration je pense que de la même
façon il faut qu'on se donne l'objectif
d'avoir pas plus fait un écart qui n'est
pas plus que 40% et 60% entre les hommes
et les femmes dans les instances
dirigeantes des entreprises ça pour est
inscrit dans la loi
ça passera par la loi oui oui on va
maintenant ouvrir le débat avec deux
parlementaires qui nous ont rejoints
dans l'audition publique
bonsoir julien dive
bonsoir vous êtes député les
républicains de l'aisne et vont soir
agité mal vous êtes sénateur ps du
val-d'oise donc deux parlementaires qui
vont débattre avec vous au cours de
cette émission alors ils vont parler
plein de choses hein ils vont parler des
délocalisations des jeunes on va y
revenir des professions sociales les
indépendants aussi on commence par ordre
alphabétique julien dive voulez parler
de délocalisation à la ministre oui mon
sens même la ministre c'est vrai que la
crise sanitaire et violente sans
précédent depuis de nombreuses décennies
et elle a un goût roulers et qui
sanitaire c'est la crise économique
crise économique voient bon nombre
d'entreprises ébranler certaines prévoit
en tout cas
disciple des fermetures certainement
tirer leur épingle du jeu des grands
groupes internationaux ont tiré leur
épingle du jeu à l'échelle planétaire
pour autant la liste s'allonge renault
auchan alinéa et plus récemment
bridgestone dans ma région des hautes
france ont annoncé des fermetures de
sites des suppressions de postes brixton
c'est environ 900 emplois qui
disparaissent vous connaissez sujet vous
vous êtes rendus à béthune ah oui
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir projet
avec plaisir je voulais attirer votre
attention sur un fait important
on a le sentiment aujourd'hui que la
législation n'est plus suffisamment
contraignante la loi n'est plus
suffisamment contraignante pour ces
grands groupes internationaux qui
prennent des décisions de loin qui
prennent des décisions de fermeture de
site avec une logique à la fois
spéculatrices est purement financière je
voudrais qu'on est tous collectivement
quelles que soient nos convictions
profondes bien ça à l'esprit qu'il est
peut être important de revoir notre
modèle de soutien à notre économie ne
pas le remettre en cause mais le revoir
quand je dis le revoir c'est peut-être
avec certaines barrières sa tête
certaines contraintes pour les aides qui
peuvent être allouées lorsqu'on
accompagne des entreprises
j'ai deux questions précise madame la
ministre la première cela concerne donc
bridgestone cas concret vous êtes venu
vous allez revenir vous ne le dirais
l'instant brixton
comment madame la ministre l'état
français
comment votre ministère comment vous
même
réussissez vous à imposer un rapport de
force allez-vous par exemple rejeté le
ps ceci n'est pas suffisamment engage
social on va dire plan social
effectivement ce n'est pas suffisamment
engageant pour à la fois les salariés
qui vont se retrouver sans emploi pour
les élus locaux qui se battent au
quotidien pour les habitants ce
territoire qui vont voir le komo tiff
économique s'effondrait et puis j'ai une
deux jardins et puis on reprendra sur le
sujet si vous permettez c'est la
différence est d'accord qui permettra de
la mine et de réfléchir les premières le
deuxième ça concerne la législation je
le disais je pense que la loi florange
ne va pas ne va plus suffisamment loin
j'avais fait
allons allons au bout des choses et
poursuivant le travail puisqu'on voit
bien qu'elle ne suffit plus au moins
dernier au mois d'octobre dernier pardon
j'avais déposé une proposition de loi
pour aller plus loin sur l'agitation
avec trois dispositifs
le premier c'était d'abaisser le seuil à
500 contre mille aujourd'hui obligeant
les amples les entrepreneurs les
employeurs qui décide la suppression
d'emplois qui décide et bien de fermer
un site est bien de devoir engager un
congé professionnels un cocher pour tous
ces salariés qui ne m'étant qui met en
lice tensions économiques mais surtout
par voie de conséquence aux biches et
employeurs à trouver un repreneur
puisque vous savez qu'aujourd'hui ils
sont obligés à partir de 1000 salariés
de la même manière de pouvoir élargir
l'ensemble des aides exigible les aides
exigible au remboursement
on sait que ce sont souvent des aides
locales moi j'aimerais qu'on puisse
s'élargir à l'ensemble des aides
nationales cic le crédit d'impôt et
cetera bien pourquoi
pour pouvoir vraiment montrer qu'en
france alors on est là pour soutenir
l'économie mais pas n'importe comment et
avec quoi je vais reprendre
pardon première chose sur bridgestone et
puis après on va aller sur la deuxième
partie graphique les mâles aura
peut-être des choses à dire d'ailleurs
sur cette loi sur les mesures d'âge sur
bridgestone je pense que c'est un 12
c'est ce que vous allez pouvoir établir
un rapport de force vous l'état avec
bridgestone c'est bien ce qu'on fait
depuis des mois avec agnès pannier en
acier en tant que ministre en charge de
l'industrie et moi en tant que ministre
du travail je peux vous assurer qu'on
pose le rapport de force avec
bridgestone agnès pannier en acier aller
sur la recherche de repreneurs pour ma
part je suis vraiment de façon très
étroite
la discussion dans le cadre du plan
social à la fois sur l'accompagnement
des salariés
je pense que les discussions sont en
train de se nouer ces décès ces jours ci
et sur un autre objectif qui fait partie
du plan social qui est l'objectif de
revitalisation savez quand une
entreprise suppriment des emplois
elle a une obligation de financer donc
il va ya voir vous allez retourner sur
place en quelques jours d'ailleurs des
choses avancent et très concrète de
façon très concrète moi je peux vous
assurer que je m'assure que les salariés
ne sont pas sans solution au mois de
décembre
on a mis en place une plateforme pour
accompagner les salariés dans leur
recherche d'emploi dans lequel il ya
tout le monde
la table évidemment l'état mais bien sûr
les collectivités qui ont un rôle très
important à jouer les acteurs
économiques du territoire
je m'assure aussi que les conditions
d'indemnisation des salariés sont
satisfaisantes peut y avoir une surprise
les congés de reclassement vous voyez on
a pris une disposition pour permettre
quand une grande entreprise de plus de
1000 salariés procède à un licenciement
il ya une obligation de congé de
reclassement
on a porté ce congé de reclassement à
deux ans et bridgestone va s'en saisir
ça permettra de mieux accompagner former
les salariés pour qu'ils lisaient
d'autant plus de chances de retrouver
des emplois donc voilà on et ça c'est
mon premier spectacle dansé sur ce sujet
sur le remboursement des aides et la
chine tbhc parce que vous devrez aller
là dessus aussi on verra mais je note
question également mais je vais vous la
pose aussi la question a surtout renoué
le dialogue sur mais juste là dessus
parce que c'est la loi montebourg je
faisais un clin d'oeil express vient
l'avez compris c'est une avancée il faut
maintenant un prolongée alors justement
est-ce qu'il faut que ça aille plus loin
et que les entreprises comme bridgestone
qui ont reçu des aides pas seulement des
aides directes mais aussi via le cicr
via les aides à l'emploi les aides aux
entreprises remboursent quand elles
délocalisent mais fn je pense que
monsieur le député c'est que bridgestone
est dans le champ de la loi florange
près jamais dû construire mairie que la
loi forget doit aller plus loin mais il
fasse que vous avez pris l'exemple que
vous avez quels exemples en tête mais
vous savez aujourd'hui lorsque sont
obligées à rembourser parce que ces
principes de la loi le scissionner par
éligibles au remboursement
il vous a pas échappé que le cic c'est
une baisse de charge donc vous avez fait
très très intégrée de charge est prête à
l'intégrer à toute charge sociale mais
pourquoi parce qu'on adore ça une valeur
mais une valeur numéraire la règle des
charges sociales en france
vous n'avez pas faim n'ont pas compensé
sur la base de ce qu'était le taux de
charge avant qu'ils baissent et pourquoi
pas puisque ont fait 1-1 donne un coup
de main c'est en tout cas ce qui me
semble très clair c'est que tout
l'argent qu'on demande à bridgestone
aujourd'hui pour moi ça m'intéresse pas
qu'ils reviennent dans les caisses de
l'état
ce qui m'intéresse c'est qu'ils
mettaient maximum d'argent c'est la loi
qui met le maximum d'argent
enfin c'est la loi il ya ce qui est
légal et il ya ce qu'on peut faire en
plus qui met le maximum d'argent pour
accompagner les salariés et qui met le
maximum d'argent dans la rebaptise
revitalisation du territoire
rajoutez balle alors je vais changer un
peu de sujet oui si vous l'avez dit un
peu dans et par un peu tu as l'air moi
j'aurais mal à ma miss vous interroger
sur la question alors bien sûr la crise
que nous connaissons est sans précédent
elle touche beaucoup des français là
dessus il n'ya pas sujet mais j'aurais m
si permet de l'éclairage sur la jeunesse
au cas les jeunes ou les jeunesse parce
que tout ça est plus complexe moi je
vous le dit traitement vous annonce
annoncé tout à l'heure des choses j'ai
entendu mais sauf qu'on sait aujourd'hui
que pour la jeunesse qui je le rappelle
en deux pays et déjà historiquement peu
la maltraiter on sait très bien que pour
beaucoup de français il ya un sentiment
que quand on est jeune il faut passer
par des difficultés notamment le fait
qu'entre 18 et 25 ans il ne se passe
rien en cas de difficultés on sait très
bien que l'accès aux marchands l'emploi
est en général très difficile plus
difficile on sait très bien que la crise
et de l'angle de de l'accès au premier
emploi que l'accès bien sûr aux études
supérieures et c est aujourd'hui
particulièrement avec le vide on voit
bien que beaucoup de jeunes ne peuvent
plus entrer dans l'arche du travail la
situation de la condition beaucoup de
jeunes qui étaient notamment des
étudiants qui a coûté de travail et ne
peuvent plus travailler on estime près
de 40 % notamment d'aider des étudiants
on sait effectivement qui a aujourd'hui
notamment autour des universités n'est
pas seulement de toute la jeunesse
l'accès de plus en plus importants à des
besoins en termes d'alimentation preuve
de première nécessité droit bien qu'il
ya un drame qui se noue vers genève
il ya eu quelques jours encore une jeune
étudiante qui s'est même suicidé à lyon
et bien sûr je pourrais ajouter les
éléments psychologiques il ya les aident
les jeunes aussi qui ne sont même pas
accès à l'université qui cherchent des
emplois qui choque la qualification qui
soit en dehors du système scolaire et
cetera et cetera et cetera alors je sais
bien que vous allez me dire que vous
avez d annoncer des choses mais j'ai
envie de vous dire que ça ne va pas la
question à ribéry parce que ce que vous
annoncez c'est notamment comme on
accompagne vers l'emploi sauf
qu'aujourd'hui le secteur et fermé
non sauf que pas dire ça vous pouvez le
dire mais sauf que ce que vous pouvez le
dire sauf que le vécu le jeune concret
c'est cela voulait rencontrer je les
rencontre alors vous plaisir etc
je voudrais revenir sur - la mesure
d'urgence parce que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est des mesures
d'urgence on a besoin vous dit on va
accompagner tout à l'heure vous
l'évoquez les missions locales etc mais
ça prend du temps ça prend du temps
alors nous nous déposons et notamment
rémi garde ont un de mes collègues au
sénat propose ce que j'appelle le
minimum jeunesse qui m'a interpellé sur
twitter d'ailleurs
pour faire la raison rémy et donc je le
fais pour lui et nous déposons au nom du
groupe
ce qu'on appelle le rsa jeunes en tout
cas en tout cas la question d'un minimum
pour les jeunes c'est ça tu as fait
c'est se dire qu'en pharma rsa c'est
tabou donc c'est à bourg-madame ministre
c'est pourquoi j'entends bien gentil
mais en tout cas ce qu'on voit c'est que
sur la jeunesse aujourd'hui je crois
qu'elle est c'est-à-dire contredisent 25
ans tu peux pas être dans un trou noir
coule pas être jetés comme ça et donc
moi j'ai entendu votre collègue du
travail ministre pardon de l'économie
qui a une vision dogmatique moi ce que
je sais c'est qu'aujourd'hui la question
qui est posée
nous proposons une solution pour
concrètement dès à présent que ces
jeunes là est une aide pour voir
survivre
un minimum pour vivre ça fait comme de
et par des plusieurs départements
également proposer leurs revenus et ses
résultats
donc voilà je moi je suis attristé et
j'espère peut-être que vous avez changé
la ville que votre majorité blog sur
cela oh non je crois de dogmatisme et
n'ont pas de réalité concrète et de
mesures concrètes pour les la jeunesse
moi je peux pas laisser dire que les
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans serait dans un
trou noir savait que évidemment on le
sait les jeunes sont toujours les
premières victimes des crises c'est pour
cela qu'on n'a pas attendu que dès le
mois de juillet on a présenté un plan
absolument massif exceptionnel par son
ampleur et qui par ailleurs propose une
diversité de solutions pour prendre en
compte la diversité des situations des
jeunes il ya eu des aides à l'embauché
des aides pour les contrats
d'apprentissage d accompagnement
renforcé des places supplémentaires pour
se former sur les métiers d'avenir et
donc ces dispositifs
je vois là je dois le dire ils portent
tous ce plan il porte ses fruits
il ya eu plus d'un million de jeunes qui
ont été embauchés sur ce qui était
soutenu par les aides à l'embauché c'est
à dire les cdd de plus de trois mois où
les cdi entre le mois d'août on a
commencé à mettre en place l'aide à
l'embauché et la fin novembre
c'est à peu près autant qu'en 2019
c'est plus qu'en 2018
il ya eu on l'a dit plus de 450 mille
jeunes qui ont pu signer un contrat
j'avais beau me dire j'ai mal c'est que
c'est du coup par coup c'est pas une
mesure globale qui serait claire nette
précise pourtant si je me permets est ce
que vos leaders vous dites c'est la même
chose qu'en 2019 sauf que là il y en a
besoin de beaucoup plus
encore une fois je dis pas que vous ne
faites rien les choses ne soyez pas
caricatural je dis que je crois que il
manque des choses et c'est parce
ambitieux et je le dis il manque
notamment quand vous allez vas-y tu en
es tu sais il manque des aides d'urgence
et je crois que le rsa jeunes lignum
jeunesse pour ne pas trouver dans votre
tabou le 1000ème jeunesse je pense que
répond à une situation
et là je ne comprends pas à chaque fois
je vous donne un autre exemple on a fait
passer au sénat je dépose et la question
sur les nombreux course et quand on
demande une aide la peau cité quand on
demande une aide d'avant automatiquement
un procès ce qu'on me dit bah voilà tel
ted et vous êtes éligible à telle ou
telle aide
et donc aujourd'hui on sait qu'il ya 30
à 40 % des gens qui pourraient à des
aides diverses et variées qui ne n'ont
pas accès parce que soit ils ne
connaissent pas dispositif soit ne font
pas la demande
eh ben ça vous l'avez également refusé
alors au nom de principes
en dix ans on a d'autres dispositifs
sauf que je crois que ce qu'ont proposé
plus opérant au cnam ogerau vraiment r
je pense quoi être complémentaires et
c'est ça que ces fermetures la qui nous
apparaît nous interroge ah ça n'est pas
du dogmatisme je peux vous assurer que
ce n'est pas du dogmatisme je pense que
quand on voit ce qu'elle voulait emmener
votre jeunesse quand on voit ce qu'est
le rsa
plus personne ne pense que le rsa c'est
une voie d'insertion sur son nez sur
l'urgence absolue
la question du rsa ou du même je veux
dire que telle journée deux en même
temps mais vous ne voulez pas la répéter
je pense qu'il faut faire les yeux que
scénario 2 mais je le sénateur s'était
boutin mais si on peut parler dans dix
ans vous êtes donc d'accord je pensais
même jeunesse alors je le formulent pas
comme vous tombez je pense que ce qu'on
fait et mieux parce qu'il s'agit de rire
vous voulez les domaines toi vous vous
rejetez les populations parce qu'il
s'agit de répondre à la fois à l'urgence
du moment pour les jeunes en étant
capable de leur donner c'est le cas dans
la garantie jeunes une près de 500 euros
par mois c'est le 13 997 comment ça
c'est pas le cas parce que ça joue ça
s'est passé je ne sais pas c'est
l'emploi 497 passé en 2023 vous allez
monter en puissance est monte en
puissance il ya une urgence maintenant
j'ai pas monter en puissance et si je
dès cette année on aura deux cent mille
garantie jeunes montrent combien
d'années autres cent mille en 2020 la
dès cette année on est loin du compte
pour toute la jeunesse
tendez ce serait moi si vous nous
expliquer que cette année on propose 2
millions de solutions je vous invite
dans ja d'oise venez avec moi à cergy
pour toi sinon vous savez je vois ça je
vais vous verrez la monnaie ce qui
m'arrive de faire des déplacements
voudrais juste souligner que ce qui me
semble essentiel c'est de se dire que
l'égalité des chances c'est de donner un
accompagnement aux jeunes de leur
permettre de trouver un projet
professionnel social la semaine devant
l'accompagner mais je crois que les
banques alimentaires et dans quel
mauvais temps lille 2 en même temps et
les banques alimentaires c'est
aujourd'hui c'est aujourd'hui que là je
ne peux pas payer son loyer qu'elle peut
pas manger quelques pas remplir son
frigo
quelle belle à se payer le minimum vital
c'est aujourd'hui l'argent vous dames la
ministre c'est aujourd'hui si ce n'est
pas demain lorsque la situation et
commencer par l'urgence commencer par
l'urgence je pense que vous ressentez
notamment la situation des étudiants moi
je peux vous assurer que tous les
cheveux qu'ils ont signé un contrat
d'apprentissage qui ont pu être
embauchées qui vont être dans une
formation professionnelle dont on est
revenu avec trois alors stade automne à
revaloriser la rémunération de garde
sont insurgés par boon avec moi moi
depuis moon avec moi voir les étudiants
de cergy pontoise
mais avec plaisir alors à jour vise
alors alors alors comme ça vous amènera
lcp avec plaisir et c'est l'un des
jeunes en saas très vite je vous demande
de poser une question rapide s'il vous
plaît julien dit vous voulez parler des
indépendants cette fois oui madame la
ministre pour connaître la situation est
extrêmement compliqué à gérer des
dispositifs ont été mis en place pour
mettre sous cloche l'économie éviter que
quelques à l'eau au moment de la reprise
économique
d'ailleurs les parlementaires ont aussi
joué dans leur travail là dessus quels
que soient leur hémicycle
premièrement première non seulement vous
voulez rapide la conclusion on estime
que d'ici 30 d'ici courant de l'année
2021 avec la reprise 30 à 40% des
indépendants seront en faillite
situation de faillite fermeront leurs
activités pour certains d'entre eux ça
fait un an qu'ils n'ont pas à travailler
pour autant aucun d'eux n'a été
identifié comme foyer épidémique en
france jusqu alors madame la ministre
pour cela aujourd'hui à 0 filet de
sécurité il sert pas il
parti à la case départ je voulais savoir
à quel moment comptez vous engager le
débat sur l'assurance chômage des
indépendants alors enfin je pense qu'on
ne peut pas dire qu'on n'a rien fait
j'ai pas dit ça m'a dit je pense qu'il
ya eu le feu les prêts garantis par
l'état
j'imagine que vous parlez des
restaurateurs je crois que vous avez pu
voir qu'on n'a pas cessé de renforcer
les dispositifs est pas différent et une
je pense que je les ont protégés qu'il
puisse y avoir besoin de mesures
complémentaires en faveur des
indépendants c'est précisément ce que
alain griset est en train de regarder
comment on peut mieux protéger les
indépendants moi je viens vous savez les
indépendants a pas seulement les
restaurateurs enfin tous ceux qui seront
alors qu'on dispose protéger les indiens
dépendance à dire alors qu'on comme de
ce projet les activités économiques en
général comme les assurances chômage des
indépendants chômage des études dans le
programme des matches mais du coup ça a
été mis enfin sa a été créée par la loi
en 2019 sur un dispositif dont les
critères sont lui mais très resserrée
extrêmement restrictif en réalité peu
d'entre eux ayant accès et vous savez
aussi que le montant est extrêmement
faible alors le but c'est pas le montant
le but c'est de pouvoir assurer un filet
sécurité à tous ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui face à une situation
inextricable avec une situation
économique est extrêmement violent pour
qu'ils subissent et on remet pas en
cause les appliquent des interdictions
et jusqu alors sur les commerces de
proximité les restaurants ont joué le
jeu dans leur grande majorité simplement
vous savez que même ce qui était mis en
place fin 2010 9 n'est pas une assurance
chômage c'est un dispositif qui auront
accès sous certains critères alors vous
avez raison de dire que ça n'est pas une
assurance chômage puisqu'il n'ya pas de
cotisations donc c'est en effet un
dispositif un peu exceptionnelle qui
leur permet à ceux qui renoncent à leurs
activités qui ont fait faillite dans un
certain nombre de cas de bénéficier
d'une aide pendant qu'ils recherchent un
environ 800 euros pendant six mois mais
je pense que la question au delà elle
sujet si on veut aller sur un système
beaucoup plus ouvert et vous pose la
question moi je suis favorable à ce qu
on n'accompagne les indépendants dans la
crise dans l'ensemble de julia leigh
êtes vous favorable à un système
d'assurance chômage je pense qu'il
faudrait commencer par demander aux
indépendants s'ils souhaitent entrer
dans l'assurance chômage ce qui veut
dire aussi payer des cotisations pour le
compte d'axa risque de compliquer sinon
c'est des salariés qui payent des
cotisations pour les indépendants la
compensation je préfère de loin on a
besoin de travailler avec les
indépendants pour s'assurer que les
protections qui ont été mises en place
ont bien fonctionné et complétée le cas
échéant et voir avec eux quel type de
protection il souhaite mais vous fermait
pas la porte à une assurance chômage les
indépendants moi je ne ferme la porte à
rien je dis simplement qu assurance
chômage ça veut dire cotisations et que
mon ma compréhension du point de vue des
indépendants ça n'est pas qu'ils ont
envie de payer une assurance chômage
l'avs exercice rachid tu es mal une
dernière question rapide rapidement moi
je voudrais parler de ce qu'on a appelé
les hommes et les femmes qui ont entre
guy mettre en première ligne
c'étaient les termes je pourrais du
primate huis clos lui-même parce que on
les applaudit on a fait beaucoup de
choses etc
mais force est de constater et jeu je
m'appuyais pour être rapide sur la
notamment le texte du secrétaire général
de la cdt laurent berger notamment sur
les hommes et des femmes il le dit
qu'ils gardent nos enfants qui s'occupe
des personnes âgées et donc il m'est
s'agir de la deuxième ligne mais ils
sont importants quand même je crois que
c'est la première ligne aussi parce que
non mais si on commence à faire que dans
l'aisance dans les termes qui était
employé au printemps mais on parle
présent que j'ai changé je la voulais
franchement c'est pas quand mais je
pourrais aussi parler de les questions
etc etc
ces deux personnes qui ont assuré à
l'eau au printemps dernier et qui
continue je crois cuilhé un
fonctionnement entre pays et je crois
qu'ils ont permis de passer cet homme
extrêmement difficile et je remonte
c'est donc sur la tribune puisque il
pointe le scrutin général c'était
l'année c'est de deux augmenté leurs
salaires que je lui sont très largement
à 15 heures 115 500 et donc la question
qui est posée et vous favorable à cela
je suppose que ça nécessitera des
négociations mais est ce que votre
ministère souhaite que toutes ces
premiers aux seconds inapte l'état comme
vous les montrer à ces hommes et ces
femmes qui ont beaucoup âgés pour nous
soit dorénavant non pas seulement
remercier avec des avec des
applaudissements amateurs mais aussi
avec des assurances de la monnaie ce
n'est pas parce que je crois que c'est
ça qui compte aujourd'hui mais mon
ministère souhaite absolument que cette
reconnaissance qu'on a pu exprimer sous
forme d'applaudissements se traduisent
concrètement pour ses salariés
c'est pour ça qu'on a ouvert une
concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux
précisément sur les travailleurs de la
deuxième ligne
ce sont des sujets qui ne sont pas
simples parce qu'elle plusieurs secteurs
professionnels qui sont cons ces
solutions pour elle il faudrait et qu'il
faudrait il faudra que les branches
professionnelles se saisissent de ce
sujet ça peut être des enjeux de
rémunération ça peut être des enjeux de
formation s'appelait des enjeux de
précarité dans l'emploi
ça peut être des enjeux de déroulement
de carrière ça fait partie de notre
agenda social dont on parle avec les
partenaires sociaux
je peux vous assurer que je suis
déterminé à avancer sur ce schéma
d'alger et à la négociation je pense que
l'état va dire qu'il souhaite et les
souhaits ses souhaits parce qu'une
négociation c'est bien sûr normandie on
sait très bien que notamment je pense
aux écoles soit de l'état mais je
souhaite mais l'état le principal le
président de la république au l'axé
majeur de la république l'a exprimé très
clairement au moment de la crise il a eu
l'occasion ne leur réussit un emprunteur
jr dans plusieurs on a été bien occupé
en même temps de fuir pas sur les
masques sur les états unis
je suis parfaitement consciente de
l'impatience qui a chez ces travailleurs
de la deuxièmee je veux vous assurer que
c'est un chantier parfois touché par le
cottier prioritaire sur lequel on avance
avec les partenaires sociaux
et moi je compte bien que les branches
professionnelles concernées prennent
leurs responsabilités pour aider l'état
il est temps que les rats d'enfance
l'armée l'état l'état et même le dernier
l'état veut mettre sur la table en celui
de difficultés rencontrées et de
l'argent savait que cette fin juillet ne
s'est pas forcément l'état qui rémunère
les caissiers et les caissières mais
passionnant mais par contre c'est très
bien que moi que vous pouvez réagir sur
d'autres éléments et je parlais pas des
états gens se pressent des rats est
déterminée à ce qu'on trouve des
solutions pour les travailleurs de la
laiterie financière mais qu'on trouve
des solutions y compris financières bien
des leçons savez on a un certain nombre
de branches professionnelles dans les
rémunérations sont inférieurs dans le
salaire conventionnel est inférieur aux
semis surtout dans ces métiers là
évidemment sur jean son pays au soudan
ces messieurs assez pénalisant on va
faire à des détenteurs des temps
partiels pour beaucoup beaucoup de son
parti à elle des sas jobim et à parler
d'égalité homme femme
on va faire des tours maintenant par le
figaro là il retrouver vincent roux
bonsoir vincent qu'est-ce que les grands
sites yahoo live aux lecteurs qui sont
aussi nos téléspectateurs sur quoi
veulent t'ils interpellé la ministre
écoutez bonsoir elisabeth bornes il y a
ce soir une longue enquête qui a été
publiée sur le site du figaro sur la
ferme il harcèle l'ennemi l'asse cet
adolescent qui est obligé de se cacher
après avoir tenu des propos très crus
sur l'islam
en réaction à des menaces de viol à des
menaces sexistes à son endroit
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez répondre à cet
internaute quand il écrit
on voit ici toute la lâcheté de ce
gouvernement qui peine à soutenir cette
adolescente alors moi je suis pas
capable de vous décrire exactement les
mesures qui ont été prises je pense que
c'est très clair que sa situation est
inacceptable qu'on doit pas être
effectivement placée dans des telles
difficultés parce qu'on a exprimé un
point de vue et donc elle doit faire
l'objet d'une protection et je j'imagine
que c'est bien le cas
vincent comment comment on peut garantir
à cette fille qui elle pourra trouver un
emploi alors que elle est traquée et est
obligé de se cacher écoutez je suis pas
capable d'abord je ne sais pas quel âge
a mis là vous m'excuserez mais je pense
que je pense que c'est le rôle du
service public du service public de
l'emploi
dd tout le monde y compris cette jeune
fille qui a des difficultés très forte
que vous avez rappelé à trouver un
emploi et vraiment je pense qu'elle peut
compter sur sur l'action de mon
ministère pour l'aider à trouver un
emploi je ne sais pas exactement dans
quel domaine elle cherche mais si le
jour où sa formation cette journée
d'information sera terminé pour
l'instant les revend est là mais c'est
vague d'une jeune fille qui est déjà
traquer on va dire comme ça à l'école
vous imaginez pour retrouver d'aplats
une place dans le milieu du travail ça
risque d'être compliqué aussi
j'imagine qu'on devra pouvoir trouver
des solutions merci vincent et je vais
remercier les deux parlementaires qui
étaient avec nous ce soir gilles kemal
julien dive merci d'avoir posez vos
questions à la ministre qui seront
toujours des questions en plus
différente de ce qu'on a l'habitude
d'entendre
merci elizabeth bord d'avoir accepté
notre invitation à audition publique qui
revient évidemment lundi
direct à 19h30 sur les chaînes
parlementaires bonne soirée
[Musique]